[Music]
foreign
a first look at what is on the front
pages time then to see what is making
the headlines with the political editors
of the guardian and the Sun pipakrira
and Harry Cole with us from now until
just before midnight welcome to both of
you as ever we take a look first of all
at the front pages themselves the Harry
and Megan Saga is the lead for the Daily
Mail with the headline Fury at sussex's
Netflix claim of War on Megan
the express 2 calls it all-out war with
the palace accusing Harry of playing a
dirty game Harry's paper the sun Wades
in with the headline Sussex lies and
videotape the star tells its readers to
get the popcorn in ahead of what it
calls another trashing of the Royal
Family by their Royal shynesses on
Thursday pippers paper the guardian says
that Rishi sunak is to scrap compulsory
house building targets after pressure
from his back benches in what is being
seen as putting party Unity before the
national interest that is also the lead
story for tomorrow's Telegraph sunac
abandons housing Target their headline
the eye reporting that antibiotics are
to be given to all children in schools
where there's been a case of strip a as
a preventative measure meanwhile the
times has new analysis which shows that
5 million patients that's one in seven
were unable to book a GP appointment
when they wanted one in October
ghost train ticket Scandal is the lead
for the Metro which says that train
companies are canceling thousands of
services without telling anyone but
still selling tickets for people to use
them the financial times says a traffic
jam of oil tankers has built up in
Turkish Waters after Western Powers
brought in a price cap on Russian oil
and turkey demands full insurance cover
for any vessels passing through while
the Daily Mirror looks ahead to
Saturday's England v France World Cup
quarterfinal with a message from Captain
Harry Kane to his team Keep Calm and
Carry On indeed so a reminder by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages Optimus papers while
you watch our guests so let's go to them
then joined by the political editors of
the guardian and the Sun pepakura and
Harry Cole should we go to the times
Harry then straight away more strikes
literally over Christmas some
suggestions they're supposed to Target
engineering works but no doubt Travelers
will also be affected by this
yeah just when it looked like um it
couldn't get any worse here it comes uh
Mick Grinch as we've named you in the
paper over the last few days not backing
down he's going to put his but they pay
off uh that was given to
um by the rail companies to the work to
the rail workers to the rail unions um
to the to his to his members but he's
gonna vote strongly urge them strongly
to vote against it look it's becoming
pretty clear that the rmt are determined
to drag this out all winter regardless
of what offer has put on the table it
was beginning to look like nothing will
be good enough
um for for him I just think it's almost
you know spiteful uh after uh the chaos
of Last Christmas when people were not
unable to get home because of Omicron
the the misery of uh the of the lockdown
Christmas before that to um to to put
the the the interests of a very vocal
left-wing minority uh before the
interests of the country like this is
yeah as I said said spiteful yeah
festive travel and tatters we see your
um you know the article in the sun there
um well what does this say to you um
pepper because some people say this is
just you know giving rail Union Workers
time off over Christmas to be with their
families and you know everyone else can
you know can just struggle on
effectively
yeah well I think
um thus far there's been quite a lot of
sympathy for not just talking about
train strikes but uh strikes across the
board because of course real workers
like everybody else nurses teachers
civil servants and all the rest of them
are considering striking are also
struggling with the cost of living I
think the the decision to
um to disrupt the nail network over
um Christmas May well end up being a
Tipping Point in terms of public support
um but the rmt is absolutely determined
to plow on it obviously represents
guards ticket office Crews cleaners and
others working on the network as left of
course is the other real Union that is
um that represents the drivers and we're
talking about the rmt specifically here
um though the tssa which is another real
Union has said that it will call off its
strike until it's passed as its members
it wants to go there first a lot of this
comes down to sort of the conditions
that are also being attached the key
point of contention and this hasn't been
a point of attention in real strikes so
over probably the last couple of decades
certainly the last decade is the desire
for the train offering operating
companies to push for uh driver only
trains so drivers would operate the
doors and would basically be in charge
of safety on the train as well and the r
t who obviously includes the member
services include the guards
um are concerned about that condition so
it's not just about the fact that
they've been off this four percent each
year pay Riser that obviously is a key
part of it it's also about the
conditions that they're being asked and
they have for example called off an
overtime ban which they were planning on
they were planning on on proceeding with
which which would obviously be
incredibly disruptive in the well-opped
Customs as well but um you know it's
going to be interesting to see we've
talked a lot in the last couple of um
people reviews we've done with you Anna
about the Tipping Point in public
empathy and I do wonder if if the the
real the r T's decision uh if the
members agree with the leadership of the
rmt to pressure head The Strokes over
Christmas May well be that Tipping Point
yeah and uh coffin makers now striking
firefighters balloting it it goes on
doesn't it no doubt we'll talk again but
let's move on to housing um housing
targets specifically and the guardian a
brick wall of opposition from some Tory
MPS and now a vault fast from the
government Harry
yeah as again as we've been discussing
over the last few weeks the problems
with the conservative party don't go
away with a new leader now what she's
doing that because that's about the
inevitable here alongside Michael Gove
the Tory majority was wiped out by
majority of MPS in the south east mostly
in the South with lib Dem facing seats
coming under massive scrutiny against
planning developments in their own
um in their own backyard so to speak and
they've been quite coordinated under the
Trees of Billy as a former cabinet
minister to say look we're not gonna
We're Not Gonna back this housing
Targets in the in the leveling up Bill
that's meant to pass come back the
commons next week was meant to come back
a couple of weeks ago but it got delayed
while they hammered this all out now the
problems that faced Boris Johnson the
proper face Liz truss are the same
problems that face Rishi sunak in the
fact that if the Tories are going to
turn it around the next couple of years
and present a you know an election
winning package to the country they've
got to do some big bold actions and that
includes getting GDP and growth up now
the quickest way to do that is to build
houses if you if every 100 000 pounds
every hundred thousand homes you build
each year it's estimated to put one
percent of growth on GDP growth now the
Tory party itself is blocking the
government from doing that so they're in
a sort of ridiculous Catch-22 where
their own party is essentially
ungovernable and stopping the party
doing the things they need to do in
order to win the next election and you
kind of Wonder you know it literally
turkey's voting for Christmas here yeah
I mean it is really fascinating I have
to say where I live um The Village has
gone up by three quarters uh in size
um no extra schooling no extra GP
Services no extra parking at the station
and
um it's changed the look of it so that
that's kind of what they're up against
Pippa you know the reality of people we
saw the by-election result we've talked
about before damage them and chesham as
well um about that you know the reality
for people living in these places which
are fundamentally changed with no extra
resource is part of the problem here
but I mean any big Housing Development
that gets built should come with
stipulations that it also
um provides amenities I mean the
developers make money out of it there's
there's supposed to be Provisions that
they you know put it in sufficient
excuse me put insufficient sewage and
Roads
um make sure that this amenities whether
it's shops parking you mentioned at a
station obviously the bigger ones are
schools and some planning in some
developments if they're adequate size
um then
um then you know they they have to build
the school in return obviously it can't
then resource can't then fund the
teachers and the staff and so on
um but but those those sorts of things
should be an absolute precondition of
building new developments in in rural
areas I mean I think the politics of
this difficulty for the society touched
on is that it looks which makes Richie
synag looked like he's had to make a
decision about whether he's more
interested in in um the prospects of the
country whether it's growth or indeed
the sort of intergenerational issues
about provide adding housing often
cities rather than in in small towns but
also in small towns um for for younger
people struggling to get on the on the
housing ladder on the one hand or
whether he's more interested in Tory
party Unity
um we've seen huge divisions across a
whole range of different issues on
inventory party in the last couple of
years and um Rishi cynic has already
delayed the legislation the going
through the leveling up Bill
um to sort of resolve this particular
issue and clearly he's made a decision
that rather than rely on labor votes to
get through an issue which uh has a huge
I mean potentially up to 100 Tory Rebels
um and cause more more divisions in his
own party
um he um he would rather really sort of
step back and and
um and proceed with the you know the the
sort of the lack of the lack of house
building instead which I think the
opposition party is almost certainly
going to going to highlight in the
run-up to the next election while there
will be communities like Eurozone I'm
sure who's relieved
um there'll be plenty of others that
think at house building is an essential
requirement when growth is sluggish and
so many people are without a home yeah
no the building's all going through
where we are and the green belt was
ditched for it put it that way
um new political parties were set up to
fight it you know it's you know it's
just an example of what's being seen
across the country and very quickly two
quick stories and and this one very
serious for only parents Harry
um you know the idea that antibiotics
should be given on mass for children in
schools that have been hit by strep a
which is clearly of great concern to
people
yeah um looks like I haven't actually
read these others but it looks like a
pretty sensible precaution British
impossible Step at the
the the pandemic not suggesting anywhere
near anything anything remotely like a
pandemic but the planning and the sort
of quick action if anything the last
couple of years is take action quickly
whether even if it's expensive if you
can get on top of something quickly uh
and smother it out as soon as possible
benefits far greater down the line yes
and uh the other story we're going to
talk about
um perhaps we will next time uh front
page of the times one in seven were
denied a GP appointment
um for figures others waited for over a
month
um another very critical story but we'll
we will discuss that a bit later on lots
more still to come including
um Sussex lies and videotape the sun's
take on the upcoming World documentary
talk about that and uh the latest on
that story after this break
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview with me once again pipakura and
Harry Cole
um so it's on a number of newspapers as
you might expect Pippa uh including the
Sun as we can see
um the latest from the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex via Netflix ahead of their
docu series
yes here they are again
um it's this new trailer for The Sussex
is highly anticipated behind the scenes
docu series and we've got six episodes
with a couple and I'm quoting here share
the other side of the high profile Love
Story
um there's some there's some concern
about
um the timing of this is obviously being
launched exactly three months after the
after Harry's grandmother the queen died
and there's a feeling that
um among some commentators that is not
necessarily the most respectful timing
to do something like this and again it's
um a real sort of you know the one hand
we hear that the couple want to preserve
their privacy and on the other hand here
they are sort of you know at home with
the Kardashian style
um you know documentary about their
about behind the scenes and while I
think you know there's some very
important issues which they want to
discuss including the racism now
uh which I think
um and maybe sort of how functional the
the raw family is as an institution
I think it's sort of not very
comfortable for a lot of a lot of people
they're very fond of the royal family
um seeing them them go about it in such
a public way there are other there are
other ways of getting these messages
across
um than earning a huge amount of cash to
open your doors to the TV cameras yes
and certainly questions about the use of
images in the trailer
um trailer one
um Kate scowling this second trailer uh
certainly Robert jobson um Royal
journalist has said that one of the
images being used
um was actually at a photo call
organized by Harry and Megan they're
only three journalists there he was one
of them and then the other one that the
son picks up your paper is the image of
the press hounding Megan is really a
media at a court event with Katie Price
uh Harry
there's a certainly say you know this is
our truth this is actually what happened
there's the definitive truth and not
even be bothered to check that you're
actually manipulating images yourself
and and creating a totally false
narrative
um is one thing leaving aside the utter
tackiness of all of this
um you know at the same time the Royals
are banging their heads against the wall
um you know sort of going to war with
the crown and asking them to just point
out generally that's a drama and not you
know not all the things that happen in
it a gospel on the same on the same
network you've got these two pitching up
um you know crying into the cameras
every five minutes as they laughing all
the way to the bank on the other side of
their faces
um and uh and pumping out frankly I
think there's a word for it fake news
okay well um we we clearly heard his
plea about women who marry into the
royal family and the pain and suffering
you know clearly he
um
his mother anyways yep carry on quickly
Megan could not been more warmly
welcomed into British life into British
Society into the British sort of into
the royal family into the story like
those crowds that lined up for days and
queued for days and cheered her at
Windsor those amazing images of Windsor
Great Park and you know perhaps there is
more to the story than simply her her
truth in the fact that actually her
behavior that the substances Behavior
how they treated the queen how they
treated the Harry the other role yeah
it's probably something to explore sorry
to rush you there we were also going to
talk about Harry Kane too but it doesn't
matter lots of lots to discuss on that
Harry and uh Pippa see you soon thank
you very much indeed